protecting people from extreme heat
waves floods and forest fires
this is a very important item and we've
been able to see this over the last few
months not only in the European Union
but also the suffering of people outside
the Union
can I give the floor to Mr Pascual
Navarro Rios
you have the fluores here
president
ladies and gentlemen commissioner
once again this year Europe has endured
a difficult summer
with
um extreme temperatures and uh climate
events according to Copernicus 23 was
the warmest year that this continent has
ever seen facing these catastrophes the
European Union has once again shown its
solidarity the EU civil protection
mechanism for a number of years now has
been playing a very important role in
Europe when it comes to natural
disasters member states activate it
to free up a lot of aid
we've seen forest fires in Greece that
the president refers to
and the Civil protectionism used EU and
member State
means to
um launch the biggest
um
seaplane event against fires that we've
ever seen
nonetheless we have to do more and we
have to do better climate change
means that we're going to have to face
new types of challenges and extreme
weather events these are going to occur
more frequently and be more intense
faced with these types of phenomena
member states as well as the European
Union will have to find new ways to
ensure prevention and preparation and
responses to these type of events
we're focusing on two fronts when it
returns to responses to catastrophes the
council has worked quickly to review the
legislation for these EU civil
protection mechanism
this will allow for firefighting planes
and to ensure that we have an operative
EU Fleet
we are reaching an agreement with the
parliament on this point and I would
like to thank this house for that
I very much believe that we'll be able
to achieve success here very quickly
nonetheless an immediate response to
catastrophes is not enough member states
and EU institutions have to work more to
prevent uh natural disasters
particularly
strengthening a risk reduction capacity
using uh the work that we've already
done for example when it comes to the
work on preparedness for catastrophes
member states have to continue to work
together to open up new areas of
cooperation
to face the
um effects of climate change the
European Union will have to be more
ambitious when it comes to strategy to
adaptation to the European Union sorry
to climate change in the European Union
we're going to have to work a smarter
and we're going to have to ensure that
we work together internet with
International Partners to respond to
climate change
uh
member states will have to adapt uh the
goals that were set out in the
climate adaptation legislation this is a
key moment to ensure that we
um
strengthen our
adaptation legislation we're going to
have to ensure that we are better
prepared to face up to extreme weather
events since they're going to occur on a
more frequent basis
we have to continue to invest in
research and Innovation through Horizon
Europe to ensure that our societies are
resilient to these catastrophes and that
we can ensure better crisis management
particularly when it comes to Preparing
our
reaction to catastrophes in terms of
that we can act
more early
um
we have to ensure that we have the
appropriate means available to do this
we also have to prepare our citizens
make information more widely available
and to ensure that citizens and
volunteers are involved in civil
protection activities
clear that these extreme events are
being worsened by global warming
this is going to be a key moment to
reach the cop 28 will be a key moment to
reach a global agreement
to ensure that we have a climate neutral
economy and that we all prepare to face
up to the changes that we're going to
see
I believe that global warming can still
be limited to 1.5 degrees
the European Union has to
focus on boosting all of these changes
that are needed at Global level thank
you our next speaker from the commission
is commissioner Leonard
Mr President
is the state Secretary
honorable members
this weekend we received the terrible
news of the earthquake that struck
Morocco
and these days we are witnessing
catastrophic floods in Libya
these events remind us
that disaster preparedness and
resilience must be our ultimate goal and
our thought thoughts are with all the
victims of these tragedies
it is our ambition and commitment to do
everything we can to save lives in
Europe in our neighborhood and worldwide
let me open
with the words of Dimitris hajipotis a
victim of the wildfires sweeping Greece
this summer
I quote
my life is now stopped
everything is taken by the fire
end of quote
the wildfire in the Eros region of
Greece has been the largest recorded in
Europe ever
burning an area of almost 100
000 hectares
meanwhile in the same country Greece a
week ago three years worth of rain fell
within two days
in August
two-thirds of Slovenia was underwater
in May
flooding in Italy prompted 900
landslides
last summer nearly 62 000 Europeans died
from record-breaking Heat
and I'm sure you can continue this Grim
list yourselves
the horrific regularity intensity and
simultaneity of these emergencies was
unusual just a few years ago now it's
all too familiar
and I'm afraid it will only carry on
accelerating
to continue keeping people safe in these
new risk landscape
we urgently need a more disaster
resilient Europe
we must build prevention preparedness
and response into every part of our
society
this summer Europe's response capacities
were strengthened like never before
we fulfilled the promise made by
President Van Der Lyon last year
to double our rescue firefighting air
fleet to 28 planes and helicopters
pre-positioning firefighters and
implementing a wildfire prevention
action plan and including a support team
in the eu's emergency response
coordination Center to monitor wildfires
in real time
in fact 18 firefighting planes and
helicopters sent to help combat the
flames in Greece this summer came from
our Collective Reserve rescue Fleet
in a dire sign of the need also to
strengthen National reserves other
member states could not send
reinforcements due to their own high
state of wildfire alert
we are facing multiple challenges
simultaneously
in July and August alone the
commission's emergency response
coordination Center handled 12
activations
ranging from wildfires and floods to the
gas explosion in Romania ongoing
assistance to Ukraine and support for
the repatriation of EU citizens from
Niger
the EU civil protection mechanism
Europe's Disaster Response system is
already working at full operational
level
over just two years requests for
assistance have increased by 400 percent
and resources are strained to the limits
soon we might not be able to help where
needed
clearly we must continue to strengthen
our Collective Disaster Response
capacities
this is why the commission requested the
reinforcement of both the solidarity and
emergency aid reserve and the
flexibility instrument within the
multi-annual financial framework
revision
whether we can continue delivering in
the coming years be it nationally or
jointly depends on the decisions we make
today
the current very limited EU budget for
civil protection is not enough
we need more financial reinforcement to
protect people
honorable members the past four years of
this European mandate have demonstrated
clearly that unprecedented disaster
demands unprecedented cooperation and
action
yet they have also reminded us that
Disaster Response alone will not be
enough
to maintain a livable future
and survive this brutal new normality we
must not only increase our response
capacity we must also ensure that when
disasters strike we are more resilient
and the impact is smaller that means
more and better investments in
increasing prevention and preparedness
in civil protection and in climate
resilience across the board across all
EU policies and programs as well as at
National levels
finally
we must keep the climate mitigation
ambition
urgent and high on our agenda so that we
do not face a future defined by
disasters that outstrip our capacity to
protect
it is our responsibility to act together
and fast for the union that protects
Europeans like Dimitris and for a
livable future for all of us thank you
[Applause]
does what thank you
Mr Vangelis uh Marcus you have the
flosser
thank you Mr President colleagues
the new parliamentary period
unfortunately began with a terrible
tragedy in my country of Greece with
huge economic and social consequences
these extreme climate phenomena
have been afflicting Greece since the
summer began first of all fires and then
terrible floods which cost tens of
people their lives
is occurred in uh started off in
thessately and spread out to the whole
country my part of the country was
particularly badly affected
people are literally out in the street
and the fact because of their houses
being destroyed
and this is still happening thousands of
houses have been destroyed 22 percent of
agricultural land has been destroyed
huge numbers of bridges and the uh Road
networks in Sicily have been destroyed
as well
Greece is suffering from its wound I'd
like to thank you Mr commissioner for
your kind words as well as the council
but we can't simply stick to words we
can't
just allow that we need to move to Deeds
we need to take steps in All Greek MEPS
call upon you regardless of their
political group to carry out powerful
steps to help and mobilize all of the
financial and other
possibilities that the EU offers to help
Greece but not just Greece of course but
all the other countries that have
suffered so badly because of this we
need to get round and cut through the
red tape and emergency circumstances
like this they can't be hiding behind
protocols we need to realize that we're
talking about our fellow citizens about
people's lives we need therefore to the
see the EU show real
solidarity and show that it's real got a
Humane heart thank you very much Mr
President
thank you chair
well this summer you can't escape it the
extreme weather floods in Slovenia
and huge uh hail in Northern Italy and
serious fires and heavy rainfall in
Greece Europe is faced with huge
challenges to adapt to this extreme
weather pattern we need which has come
closer than we ever expected climate
change is not just something that will
happen in the future it is something
that is here and extreme weather is
really producing more damage it is our
responsibility to reduce this damage so
help solidarity for the areas affected
is very important but we need to make
sure that we're better prepared for what
we may see in the future if we want to
reduce the impact of the weather
patterns this is no plan B any longer
this is a Here and Now situation thank
you thank you so much
trauma
I'd like to give the floor to Mrs
you have the floor
thank you president
the first thing I would like to say is
to express solidarity with victims of
disasters in Morocco Libya and here in
Europe Greece summer of 2023 has
um set records when it comes to the
temperature the warmer summer at Global
level
uh the Mediterranean has reached the
highest temperatures ever seen at 28.71
degrees
and in Greece we saw more waterfall in
two days than the last three years so
Europe is an at-risk area for natural
disasters
climate change is being caused by global
warming and we need to have a European
plan for prevention and adaptation and
mitigation and a resilience plan to face
up to these changes
however we also have to keep in mind
that the best type of resilience the
best response to natural disasters is
to ensure that nature is more resilient
we need to restore nature this is a
fundamental objective of this plan
now is not the time to ask for a
moratorium on the green deal now is the
time to speed up we need to see more
being invested in prevention to put an
end to these types of disasters thank
you
thank you Mrs Terry Reinke you have the
floor madam
colleagues serious floods and forest
fires we've really had an extreme
weather pattern in Europe
80 000 hectares have burnt in Slovenian
floods have led to half a billion damage
and a large part of the country was
affected and in the out Valley there was
even more damage because of the floods
and the results of the floods nobody can
say that do nothing is better cheaper
than to actually start doing something
about this these extreme weather
patterns over the next few years are
going to cost us millions of Euros Hill
rain floods is going to have a
devastating effects for citizens in
Europe and the heat waves already costs
the lives of so many people too so we
know this and despite all of this
despite this reality there are
politicians who say that and maybe we
need a break first a break which would
mean that the weather patterns which get
even worse in the future and then we'll
need to take even more Desperate
Measures to fight against this situation
no no breaks no breaks no pauses no we
need to continue the climate crisis the
effects of the climate crisis isn't
taking a rest either so we need to
handle we need to do something now this
is a politically responsible
because anything else colleagues is just
to ignore reality it's difficult to say
well if we don't do anything we'll kind
of survive even though reality hits Us
in the face so that this is seriously a
dangerous and irresponsible so we need
to make an effort because the green deal
is not a Sprint it's a marathon and as
European union we need to do more to
have citizens
being helped we are based on solidarity
and for some people
you feel that as putting millions of
Euros in to disaster relief
packages is certainly
better invested than to do nothing thank
you
thank you so much the next speaker
Mr Emmanuel farkos we must have promised
thank you Mr President
the European systems
do deal with climate issues and the
increased risk of fire and dangers of
flood but in terms of how they actually
work it's not been very impressive we
need to prevent rather than cure we need
to act quickly we need to have a proper
system of prevention particularly in
fire prone zones
we need to make certain that highly
flammable trees are dealt with and steps
are taken and we have a lot more fire
prevention drones in the air what we
need to do is check the way that regions
and municipalities interact with each
other when it comes to fire protection
we need to look at the farmers in Greece
the beekeepers all of the people who
have suffered under these situations
because prevention is actually cheaper
than the subsequent work that a rescue
work which has to be carried out just
look at thetally and everos it's
important that Europe needs to have a
complete re overhauling of this system
it's more important than ever that we do
this work not just for the good of
Greece but for Europe in general we need
a new plan to prevent disasters
developing it in Europe and making
certain that it's interoperable if you
look at what's happened in thesally you
can see that Europe is able to act after
the fact we've got the solidarity fund
we've seen attempts to help farmers out
under the cap and also help out
smallholders who've stopped Earth's been
so badly affected by the floods thank
you president Madam Sylvia
thank you Mrs Sylvia Sedona you have the
floor
disasters the
green strategies seem to
have an effect I mean if we would have
built the proper proper dams we wouldn't
have had the floods in the north of
Italy if we would have cleaned the
rivers dikes dams all interventions
which we needed to deal with but they
seem to go against in your policies the
natural disasters such as floods need to
be uh solved by more structures built by
men now two months to talk about hot
heat waves and then you realize that the
data say the opposite there's been a
drop of 3.3 percent in energy
consumption in Italy and from one year
to the next and the average temperature
did not really show a huge increase now
there's been a drop of not
0.3 degrees compared to the previous
reads so you know this is not the
Apocalypse
let us have fewer serious debates on the
climate
storage
this you have the floor
two months ago for the first time in the
world we moved beyond the 1.5 degree
limit
these disasters throughout the globe in
Europe are absolutely terrifying and
we've seen the new records in terms of
damage caused our policies are
destroying people's lives and are
actually threatening the survival of
democracy things are getting worse and
worse and people aren't being helped
properly by the state the solidarity
fund isn't big enough to deal with the
scope of the problem
small countries in Europe such as Greece
my own country is suffering in
particular time has come to re-jig these
funds and to come up with some kind of
compensatory fund for people who have
suffered under these disasters
solidarity is vitally important it's
important that we don't have any
exceptions when it comes to paying these
compensation because we if we mobilize
article 107 to B of the Treaty of the
European Union we can do something about
the people who have suffered so much
we need help and we're calling for your
solidarity as well thank you
thank you
thank you so much uh Mr Lefteris you
have the floor
siros is still smoking with the biggest
fire in the history of Europe 19 people
dead a hundred thousand hectares
destroyed in
thessally thousands of complete all
whole Villages have been cut off people
are without food without electricity
exposed and there's no help for them
we can see that however with them
Grassroots organizations have been
helping giving new life to the slogan
only the people can help the people the
criminal responsibility of the EU and
Bourgeois government is obvious when it
comes to the so-called climate crisis
the means to stop these phenomena
turning into tragedies exist but they're
not being used because of the eu's cost
benefit approach adopted by All Greek
governments directives talk about
avoiding the excessive costs of flood
protection and with economic efficiency
whole Villages which could have been
saved have been abandoned
what we need to do is make certain we
rescue the people who have been cut off
right now that we adopt all the
protection measures that we need as the
state's responsibility and that we start
and equip the staff and equip the
firefighting and Forest protection
services and that we compensate to the
tune of 100 all the people who have been
affected and that all the requisite
European funding be mobilized to that
effect thank you Chelsea Manuel thank
you Mr Jose Manuel Fernandez thanks very
much Mr President colleagues
commissioner and the council
representative every year we
say how terrible it is that we've got
these fires we've got these floods we've
got these deaths but we need words but
we also need deeds and that we're not
doing enough there's you've got the
money in the council
and all of the money for example wasn't
always used in Portugal what we need to
do is
have dams built so that we have water in
reserve for a drought so we can plan
ahead and help develop the European
economy there's no lack of Financial
Resources we need to plan and spend them
wisely and over and above prevention
which is the best solution we also need
of course to fight these disasters as
well and the commission often against
the desires of the council has done its
job by strengthening the European civil
protection mechanism strengthening
Rescue Services we with fewer resources
are able to do more if we shared out
these resources and coordinated things
we can do a great deal
that's why we are asking for everyone to
work together in this fight and after
everyone doing their own homework and
that we don't
use
people but we don't see people blaming
Europe for this when they do have money
at home that are not always spending the
European Union the European Council
Parliament we all need to do our jobs
that member states need to pull together
as well thank you thank you
uh you have the floor Mrs guamini
Francisco
well the ecological transition is is is
a safety net
we say that the left and the right work
together on so many subjects but this is
not pretty true in climate change
there's a right and there's a left the
votes are different the behavior is
different strategies are different the
right uh has turned Echo skepticism into
its slogan and they fight against the
Green deal which is the need to fight
against a devastating climate change but
we are in favor of mitigation adaptation
you however uh it's a way that you say
well it's been hot we protect nature you
are negationists we want to have
renewable sources and news seem to be in
love with fossil fuels we want to
safeguard the future but you want to
safeguard the past we've seen this in
media Romania a right-wing government
which is carrying out a negative policy
which does not call upon a solution so
let us try and ask ourselves whether we
want to continue with the green deal
because the political forces seem to be
going in opposing directions tell the
truth are we going forwards or not thank
you
Mr maxarville you have the floor
in July 2023 we saw the highest
temperatures ever registered forest
fires devastated a large number of
European countries including Greece just
uh 72 hours ago Morocco Morocco
witnessed a devastating earthquake and
Europe stands by Morocco the European
Union Civil protection mechanism is an
effective and useful tool to face these
challenges we have to strengthen it
and it showed that we have a human
material and financial Ambitions in
doing so this is through prevention
training and raising awareness through
populations about what they should do in
cases of major risks it also means that
we have to increase European capacity to
intervene with our own seaplanes and uh
jointly buying material
disasters are hitting the world and are
doing so on on a more frequent and
stronger basis we've seen cyclins in the
um until East
and fires in the Canary Islands the
outermost regions are the first to be
affected by climate change they need
specific retention they need to have
specific climate Solutions and their
experience can help the rest of Europe
thank you Mr Boss aycott you have the
floor sir thank you Mr chairman first of
all what we're seeing again this summer
and what we are seeing nowadays every
summer and winter is the new climate
reality this is exactly what science has
been warning for and we will see it more
because the warming of our planet will
lead to more extremes
and we are not prepared to deal with
those extremes and that's what we have
seen again this summer first of all I
really would like to thank the
commission for already pushing for a
couple of years now the EU civil
protection mechanism and really a plea
to the council to now finally move
substantially on that because every time
when we are discussing this and
especially after the summer we are
mourning the victims of climate extremes
but every time the council is not really
putting the money where their mouth is
so in that sense a lot to be done but we
need to step up we need to step up we
need to prevent and that is also using
our nature it's a best buffer capacity
for water shortage and water extremes we
need to create more space for rivers in
order to make sure that we can cope with
the extremes of our climate system but
most importantly we need to step up our
speediness towards a fossil-free economy
because that's the only way to prevent
more of this thank you
foreign thank you
president commissioner the European
commission is neither transparent nor
open
it is lobbying for dubious green
policies based on unscientific claims it
is based on lobism which tries to change
the way in which we Europe generate
energy and the way in which economies
work this is against the interests of
European citizens and European
entrepreneurs
this is a fact when I asked the European
commission how much is the green deal
what does it cost they say thank you for
the question when we ask how much did
the vaccines cost they say thank you
when we ask what is the cost of the
production of an electric vehicle they
say thank you for the question well this
is a wall of lack of transparency whose
purpose is to
is to stop the development of Europe
this will make us dependent on external
Mr kirokmaya you have the floor sir
thank you
thank you thank you honorable uh
president
well extreme weather has always existed
don't pretend that this is something new
and even in my region this summer in the
south of stimach but we had huge floods
after a heavy rainfall well yes it leads
to human suffering human suffering but
on the other hand
a certain livelihood is threatened
because of the damage caused by these
heavy uh floods of course we need to
provide Aid and support and people need
to be on the spot the voluntary
firefighters who have fought huge
battles against the fires this summer
and we need to and we need to thank them
because if not This Disaster would have
gone in a completely opposite direction
so these organizations
in Austria are mostly voluntary
organizations and they shoulder these
response abilities they need special
support and we need to see what we can
do there are many specific measures that
can be taken to protect people
adapt adaptation to heat adjusting to
floods this is more expensive but you
apparently want to sink this into the
dark channels of the Ukraine rather than
working on this disaster Mr Urich you
have the floor
Junction
with treasure consequences or heat waves
forest fires and floods at recently seen
in Greece Cyprus and other European
countries show that there is still
lessons to be learned and actions to be
taken
the vulnerability to our societies
remain very high despite important
progress in the cooperation amongst
countries and investments in advance
equipped
over sorry scientists have warned us
long time ago that we used to consider
extreme and unlikely probable is now
becoming business as usual
our infrastructures and protection need
to adopt as fast as possible to be
changing climate conditions it is
appropriate in timely Human Action
allows climate change to become climate
crisis
the complexity of disasters implies
timely planning and demand high-level
Dynamic responding governance against
climate related life-threatening risks
we need centralized management we may be
EU handle the pandemic may be a good
example namely Collective monitoring
Collective action thank you
thank you
thank you colleagues
the next speaker I don't quite see that
she is here
so Mr Mato you have the floor
thank you presidents I want to just give
you one figure 88
000 hectares burned in Spain in 2023 the
results of this have been particularly
tragic in the Canary Islands
and particularly in Tenerife where
almost fifteen thousand seven percent of
the surface of the island has been
destroyed 80 million euros but the
damage has been caught we need to learn
from these disasters and ask us what
needs what strategies and policies will
be appropriate it's not on the the
Canary Islands should require these
planes which can dump water or
helicopters all the time because they
take hours to arrive from the mainland
to the islands we need to strengthen our
cohesion policy in the solidarity fund
and the Civil protection mechanism
it's also important that member states
work to conserve and protect and prevent
and restore our forests
or finally it's vital that the European
Union draft a support strategy for the
whole primary sector which in the light
of these is really living on the edge
and can't handle these issues by itself
we need help and everybody does thank
you thank you
thank you Mr uh saliska view you have
the floor
thank you President we cannot deny what
is obvious the climate crisis is here we
saw this summer
extreme weather conditions floods heat
waves and wildfires
some member states
in a few days had to go through heat
waves and extreme floods in Malta the
smallest member states we had record
temperatures around
43 degrees for various days and this
created great challenges for our
critical infrastructure these extreme
conditions are with us and they will be
on the increase
and this leaves a negative impact on our
quality of life our environment and our
economies therefore
we need a strategic plan and we need to
continue to invest in uh
resistance plan that will help citizens
protect them protect in this Industries
critical infrastructure and our
environmental sustainability thank you
see
Mr Martin
she helped us what
Mr Isaac you have the floor
we cannot hide from the climate change
it limits and impacts all of us people
municipalities companies States it kills
animals and humans it doesn't
distinguish this summer was another
example of that we have seen life the
extreme temperatures forest fires heat
waves but also floods in the south of
Europe Slovakia was no exception
regions extreme heat waves the Snowballs
of ping pong balls have been demolishing
grain in southern Slovakia we have seen
destruction of Hope buildings we cannot
adapt to the climate change the extreme
heat waves with high humidity is
something that human body cannot
tolerate people die
we can capture a lot of water but we
need to and we need to do that but if
you have a rainfall over three days
which is equal to the rainfall of three
years there's not much that you can do
this is exactly what has happened in
Greece therefore reducing emissions has
to go hand in hand with adaptation the
climate change will not distinguish
between the victims and the same has to
go for us it cannot divide us across
political families it has to unite Us in
the responsibility for future the bill
for Unnecessary disputes will be paid by
everyone irrespective of our political
conviction therefore we have to do our
utmost to prevent future damages
thank you Mrs married you have the phone
the planet it's experiencing a profound
climate crisis and Europe
um is not free from it we're seeing an
unprecedented fires in Greece drought in
Spain and uh problems elsewhere
and yet uh Awards continue
uh the writer is fighting the nature
restoration law you know just before
yesterday
um we saw the president of the
commission um say nothing about uh the
nature restoration law Madame mezzolla
says that
climate policies are leading to an
increase in populism in Europe and yet
this is at the same time when millions
of uh Europeans are
um experiencing The Fallout of climate
change uh what we're really seeing is
economic crises living to populism
ecological uh crises are the way in
which uh leaders can give in to lobbies
we have a system which is destroying
human beings and nature we have to
change our way of thinking uh we want to
support uh living beings and every
minute counts in doing this
is
President commissioner ladies and
gentlemen
we cannot give back the lives or the
livelihood to those who lost them who
suffered but what we can't do
now is to work now and in the future
what we need now and in the future is
money and solidarity so that we can
reconstruct our infrastructure our
livelihood
we also must carry out a thorough
in-depth analysis let me remind you
investigations are underway in many
countries as regards those fires please
bear in mind those fires in some cases
were caused by human action so
also remember there is no more money in
our system the ego budget
lacks to the tune of 65 billion euros so
now we need money for is reconstruction
is rebuilding our cities
and reforming our
streets covered with concrete all of
that costs money and that money should
be paid to our Farmers thank you very
much
thank you Mrs Rosanna country you have
the floor
is
I can still hear the sound of the hail
which fell with deep force in venator
Freely Venezia Julia and tradition
RDJ chunks of ice as big as the palm of
your hand destroying crops and cars
gusts of wind which could rip off roofs
and upbeat root root trees people and
animals
injured by this bad weather and how can
we forget the flood which occurred in
Emilia Romania a terrible disaster
but in the north east in Italy we did
respond but left-wing governments didn't
allow some of the programs to be
mobilized to respond to what a
colleague's been saying but the
Northeast region is they did respond and
react thanks to the hard work of the
people and the tireless efforts of
volunteers firemen and civil protection
officers but every extreme climate event
weakens our territory and makes our
citizens exposed to Danger Brussels
needs to forget about ad hoc measures
aimed at 2050 and ignore the problems
that our families and companies are
facing today to be genuinely resilient
States need rapid effective responses
right away now is the time thank you
thank you the next speaker Mrs Thomas
thank you for giving me the floor the
unusual weather has affected Europe and
the rest of the world and it has caused
a lot of damage extreme rainfall a
record high temperatures drought floods
storms have caused a lot of damage in
nature but have also claimed
unfortunately human lives and their
homes
in moments like these we have to fall
back on one of the key European uh
qualities and that is solidarity we are
not alone we live in a community where
we care about our neighbors about our
citizens about people in general about a
month after the terrible floods that
have affected Slovenia that have struck
two-thirds of our country I would like
to take this opportunity and thank
everyone who helped Slovenia who helped
our citizens from the European
commission to other countries and most
of all all the volunteers who came and
helped clean the devastation that was
caused by wild rivers when cameras stop
rolling however places and people still
need help and that is why I'm asking my
colleagues when the time comes to vote
to financially help Slovenia with funds
from the European solidarity fund to
vote for that help thank you very much
thank you
thank you so much
I'd now like to give the fruit to Mr
Marcos Ross and Perry please
thank you
president
heat waves fires floods heavy rainfall
these extreme weather events
are more frequent people pay very
heavily for the consequences and more
and more people suffer especially those
who are less well-off we've had the
hottest uh summer ever registered in
Spain we know this heat waves that take
longer that last longer or floods like
last week's floods the temperature of
the Seas water goes up and these heat
waves are more frequent we need to act
more firmly the path that we need to
take is clear the European green Pact
a cohesion a fund a solidarity fund the
member states and European institutions
need to take part in this path they need
to do this as a priority we need
preventive measures to face up to these
extreme phenomena and funding for the
Civil protection mechanism to strengthen
the European response
it was a threat in the past but now it
threatens the livelihood of millions of
people so we need a commitment a firm
commitment to tackle this thank you
thank you thank you so much the next uh
speaker Mrs Irene tolerant
[Music]
um
we've done some work colleagues to deal
with these issues solidarity among
states of the EU but also involving
third countries as we've seen with
Canada it's there it's working but
far too often the commission is working
with a silo-like mentality when what we
really need to do is have cross-cutting
consistent policies
when we have a law to reduce emissions
for example every time we write a law
like that we should ask ourselves is
this increasing or reducing the risk of
national disasters looking for live dead
timber for example this is something
which in our forest will reduce increase
the
risk of fire I'm not saying this off my
own but it's firemen who have been
telling me that this is the case also I
think that we need to look at the
question of pastures pasture is a key
element in preventing natural risk for
risk of natural disasters and it's also
sustainable as far as our forests are
concerned and also to resist these
things and protect our citizens we need
to have a way of raising awareness other
countries are doing this having days
devoted to this if you're on holiday or
if you're at home you shouldn't be
unaware of the risks that you run and
what you should do to prevent those
risks thank you
homegrown
thank you president
this
summer in Europe we people have seen
what it means to live in a high-risk
climate
we have already set Ambitions and yet
we're still going to have a
climate that will be two degrees
warmer
we're still going to have heat waves
floods they're going to be more serious
and more frequent
and so it means that already we're going
to have to focus on better adaptation to
climate change
but uh what's the most important
particularly in light of next year's
elections is that all countries or
political parties all Industries have to
be more ambitious when it comes to
cutting emissions
time is pressing we have to change the
world to be able to face up to the
challenges that lie ahead of us but time
is kicking by quickly
the next speaker Mrs perennial Vice
thank you we have an EU that is equipped
for disasters we need to discuss this
but what we need to do is to deal with
this the crisis has many causes many
actors and
this plays
either you are clearly indicate that
something is not functioning properly
and others are taking advantage of those
of this during an electoral period so
we're focusing on the EU green deal but
this of course also means that the
agenda for the elections has been set
aside and today especially in the
situation of water we need to act
jointly and hopefully colleagues you
will be able to find my email I drafted
a letter together with the
ewas and we're sending this to the heads
of state and government where we call
upon governments to over the next
legislative period we get a blue deal we
don't have proper future if we don't
take serious care of our Water Resources
so we need to deal with this and
if not water is going to flood us thank
you
Mrs thank you president colleagues
this
summer will live on in our memories
because huge extreme climate events have
now become a reality we need therefore a
multi-faceted approach from the European
Union if we want to be more resilient
when it comes to climate disasters
because
people can be
affected the new
infectious diseases for example civil
protection people are looking at the
Civil protection mechanism and it's
going to be scrutinized very carefully
it's important when the commission comes
up with its ideas making this more
flexible when it comes to minimizing
health risks in disaster situations and
the long-term impact it'll have on the
people in the affected areas whether
we're talking about floods or forest
fires these are things that are part of
our everyday lives now and it's vitally
important that everybody be protected
thank you very much president yes
thank you next speaker Mrs Maria spiraki
you have the floor
thank you president commissioner
Minister colleagues the climate crisis
in Greece is a terrible tragedy in
thetaly and Thrace people have died a
unique ecosystem has been destroyed
half of the country's water supply has
now been compromised we need to mobilize
the budgetary possibilities 20 21 to
2027 to try to deal with this we heard
these commitments being made but they
need now to become a practical reality
climate change isn't going to
ship spare anybody we need high levels
of resilience and protection we need to
start working on this right away we need
to mobilize money mobilize money to help
the people who have already suffered and
the what's in the
the solidarity fund isn't enough we need
more and the European Investment Bank
needs to provide soft loans to help
people out as well we've seen what's
happened in the last few weeks we've
seen the response from the Metro attack
is government and we've seen the people
suffering we
shouldn't allow Greece to get bogged
down in these issues we need to respond
in a way that's commensurate with a
tragedy thank you
I'd like to get the floor to Mr Miller's
next speaker
Mr President thank you for giving me the
floor in August two-thirds of slovenia's
territory were hit by terrible floods
causing billions of Euros in damage
destroying many homes damaging
infrastructure and unfortunately also
claiming human lives we have to thank an
excellent civil protection system
government offices and numerous
volunteers that have prevented the
damage from getting worse and I would
also like to thank for the response and
solidarity of other member states and
also third countries I would also like
to thank the European Union and
international organizations I'm also
pleased by the with the response and
engagement of Mr Leonard teach and Miss
Mrs Van Der Lyon the president of the
European commission who visited Slovenia
unfortunately Slovenia is not the only
country in the EU that has suffered this
summer the EU will be key to ensure a
long-term response to ensure human
safety and to adapt to everything that
is going on in our environment we will
have to quadruple the resources in the
European fund and we have to send a
clear message to Europeans to European
citizens that in their worst moments
they are not alone thank you
foreign
thank you president
these extreme phenomena in the Morocco
Slovenia Slovenia and Greece have shown
that climate change is here and everyone
is starting to suffer from it in
thetally to give you an example we've
seen houses completely destroyed
and it's something that people could
never have imagined before
the European Commission
needs to adopt emergency measures to try
to address the situation many colleagues
have mentioned this before and how we
need to support the green deal even more
firmly it's important that we try to
deal with the problems which are going
to be caused by the polluted surface
water that we are now seeing we have
measures which haven't been applied
properly until December I'd like to see
that we in the smes S and D group would
propose that we have a to-do list
involving the best practices when it
comes to addressing problems caused by
fires and floods
and the Army the firemen the police all
need to work together and we can work in
a spirit of solidarity
that's already happened in Greece and
that example needs to be followed it's
urgent that we work together and
mobilize the solidarity mechanism as
quickly as we can as colleagues have
said because I think that democracy
could be imperiled if we don't do
anything thank you
thank you
miss you Christopher short of losios
thank you president commissioner
I'd like to start by congratulating all
of those who fought these disasters
across Europe and also welcome the
European uh protectionism against crises
but what you've said is that you don't
have the means you need to fight these
crises the truth is that we don't know
all about vulnerabilities in Europe
we're seeing an index vulnerability in a
vulnerability index being developed but
it's not very um used
we need to have an adaptation plan and
we need to have a real plan to mobilize
societies the truth is that your
disaster
goals should be our common basis but
they are still in their own Silo and are
mainly intergovernmental
in reality
it's really only within this Parliament
that the
um even within this Parliament civil
protection plays a marginal role in the
parliament there is a cross-cutting
group a horizontal group
um between envy and Reggie to look at
these issues uh that could be a good
idea to work on
um in 2024 a year after your disaster
Reliance goals it would be a good idea
as well to have a high level conference
with the council the Parliament and the
commission
um so that without having to wait for
the elections we can breathe new life
into these policies to change our the
model that we use to work coming to the
khdi point I have four speakers on my
list
I will start with Mr Nemet matyash
their colleagues this summer has also
taken a toll on many countries of the EU
we've had natural accidents one after
another climate changes here with a huge
tall Slovenia has been affected by
Millennial floods this has been the
biggest natural disaster in Slovenia
that affected more than two-thirds of
our territory also six people died
damage could actually amount to 7
billion euros on behalf of all
slovenians I would like to thank all
member states for providing us with help
there is a lot of solidarity on the part
of our citizens that's why I would like
to thank all volunteers that were
actually fighting the damage of the
floods last year we were fighting floods
and I also actually sent an initiative
to the commission to set up an old
European mechanism to have Reserve
fleets to fight
fires of course the recovery will be
very expensive that's why I have an
appeal to all EU institutions we need EU
funds so please let's actually approve
the financing of the recovery
thank you so much Mrs paulus you have
the floor
president
thank you president colleagues
every single year every single decade
every single Century we are faced with
uh extreme weather conditions and that
is what we have seen in the past I mean
what have been used are computer models
we have very performing computer models
and these are then compared with what
was observed in the past so this is not
speculation and the reality clearly
shows that this is happening and many
people say we need better adjustment to
strategies yes that's correct we need to
give nature more space because natural
solutions of course are probably the
cheapest too but we need to see how
where we build what are we to rebuild
what's the point of rebuilding areas
that are affected by floods year after
year what's the point of building new
infrastructure I mean this is wasteful
our funds don't help us and even
insurance companies in the United States
will be rejecting this type of
infrastructure they would not cover this
type of uh building of infrastructure so
let us not waste any further money thank
you
Mr pimentalopas you have the floor
thank you president
we've got all these proposals and
measures to face up to national natural
disasters we need to reduce disparities
between member states and Regional
disparities
particularly protecting those who are
which are poorer and have a high
exposure levels to risk make certain
that we can live it more harmoniously
when it comes to Nature we need to help
support disaster prevention cohesion
policy and rural development policy and
Regional policy the solidarity funding
protection of the environmental response
to climate change can help here
and but we're seeing in fact a reduction
of things like this to increase the
profits of the Armament and energy
industry
we see
people who ought to be working on
protection in their member states losing
their jobs we're not protecting our
forests and money is being made by these
groups who which are basically
prioritizing their own needs over those
other people
thank you president kares
this debate
is about extreme heat waves
floods and forest fires
these events
have all happened in my region Alicante
and so
I think all of us or at least most of us
in this chamber agree that the origin
the cause of these problems
including drought as well is climate
change
and so we have to accelerate financing
for the green deal
the green deal needs a climate budget
uh we need to issue a community
um debt in order to finance all of this
but at the same time Alicante in my
region needs some kind of a system for
the torrent to deal with the torrential
uh rain that we're currently dealing
with the commission has to make more
efforts here
we also have to ensure that we have a
system which will move water to where
it's required during times of drought or
uh uh uh up drought and so we need to
ensure that the commission can help us
with this as well thank you
[Music]
thank you so much I'd now like to ask
commission Council for their final
comments commissioner leonardich you
have the floor
Mr President honorable members I do
thank you for this discussion and I want
to thank in particular
to the voices of support for the Union
Civil protection mechanism
indeed even in an unprecedented
challenging year like this one
not a single request for assistance
addressed through the Union Civil
protection mechanism went ananswer
and yes in view of the worsening risk
landscape
we need to further strengthen this
mechanism
but we also need faster
smarter and more systemic climate
adaptation
we need strengthening of the resilience
of our ecosystems
because nature is our first line of
defense against disasters
this way we will be able to protect
people and to ensure that the damages do
not surpass our capacity to manage them
the European Union is already taking
action
to strengthen its Collective resilience
against disasters
this February we adopted as it was
already mentioned
the European disaster resilience goals
to assist both the union and the member
states to better anticipate
and withstand future emergencies
and these goals must now be rolled out
across Europe
simply to keep people safe
investments in preparedness and
prevention save lives
they protect communities and spare
budgets
every Euro invested in prevention and
preparedness can save from 5 to 10 euros
in response
while average annual losses due to
weather and climate related disasters
already total 14 billion euros across
the Union
there is some good news for instance
that the investment in resilience
is indeed increasing
for instance allocations under the
cohesion policy have nearly doubled
allocations for disaster resilience from
7 billion euros during the previous mff
to almost 13 billion in the current mff
and also the new instrument for
recovering resilience adds on an
estimated 12 billion
climate change
obviously more will have to be done
but no amount of preparation and
response will save our planet
unless every part of society works
together to tackle the fundamental cause
of these disasters
which is climate breakdown
and environmental degradation
without such action
we are on a certain path of destruction
this July was the hottest month on
record globally
and this is a warning of what an average
summer will be
without meaningful climate action
that's why we must continue to integrate
the European green deal across all
sectors
how much will it cost
well it will cost much much less than if
nothing is done
if nothing is done
there is a doubt that there will be a
livable future for Humanity on this
planet
indeed in my view European green deal is
our all-encompassing truly
cross-sectoral prevention strategy
in short we need more response capacity
we need more resilience and we need more
climate mitigation and adaptation
to prevent the worst
and we have many of the instruments and
mechanisms that are needed to achieve
this across the every sector of the EU
we must mobilize all of this including
common agricultural policy including
cohesion policy including recovery and
resilience facility to make this happen
and obviously we have to strengthen we
have to reinforce solidarity and
emergency aid Reserve
and we must use
the midterm point in the multi-annual
financial framework to reassess the
funding that is devoted to disaster
prevention and climate resilience
and I really encourage the parliament to
support this important cause during the
ongoing review process thank you
thanks
thank you female
thank you so much commissioner I'd like
to get the floor to Mr Navarro Rios
please for on behalf of council you have
the floor sir
president honorable members Mr
commissioner Leonard I I very much
welcome the debate that was held that
was held today that is to have more uh
response uh prevention and reaction
measures in the union and I reiterate
the solidarity of council with Greece
and also other Mediterranean countries
that have suffered from uh disasters
when we talk about adjustment to climate
change and resilience
we need to face up to challenges and
deal with these challenges but also have
sustainable transition and fair and
Equitable transition I take note of the
proposals tabled by commissioner
leonardich and I'd like to point out
that councilors thinking of the
council's the commission's proposal for
the multi-annual financial framework in
the proposals table by the Commission in
the different areas that were
highlighted today in order to prevent
the disasters caused by climate change
we need to have an intersectral approach
where adaptation is at the very heart of
these measures and council is prepared
to examine any legislative proposal on
prevention measures which as was said
today for the time being our non-binding
uh rules and it is also prepared to
consolidate all the measures for
coordination non-binding coordination
measures and thank you so much for your
attention because you don't yeah thank
you so much uh president to council this
debate is now concluded and this brings
us now to the next item on our agenda
that is the commission and Council
statements on the EU Tanisha agreement
and